[موسيقى]
في هذا الطريق الهادئ ليس بعيدًا عن
معبر شيبويا الشهير في طوكيو ، يوجد
مطعم متواضع به ستة مقاعد فقط ،
ولكن كل ليلة
تقريبًا يزوره بعض من أبرز الأسماء اليابانية
هذا المساء لا يختلف عن
ذلك فقد جاءوا لرؤية  المرأة التي
تدير العرض
[الموسيقى]
كل ما
تقدره
لأنها قادرة على الاندماج فيه ، أنت
تعرف عالم الطهي ،
إنها فنانة وأيقونة ثقافية
يتحدث عنها ناتسوكو شوجي
، هي طاهية تبلغ من العمر 32 عامًا وصاحبة
ete معجنات حائزة على جوائز  متجر
ومطعم يجمعان بين
الطهي الفرنسي الحديث والمكونات اليابانية الموسمية الطازجة
من البريوش
إلى سمك القرميد المقرمش
إلى عشاء الحلويات الشهير
دائمًا ما يكون أمرًا مريحًا ولذيذًا
إحدى الطرق التي تبرز بها
هذه الخصائص المختلفة
مثل أومامي وإعجاب الشخصيات الخفية من
النكهات المختلفة
هي عن طريق وضع أطباق
خفيفة ومنعشة للغاية متبوعة
بشيء جيد جدًا  إن
مذاق الطعام اللذيذ يأتي
من تدريبي وفي المكونات المحلية التي
أستخدمها ، لكن الأهم بالنسبة لي هو
كيف يشعر العملاء بمن
يأكلونه مع
الجوانب الذهنية والعاطفية للوجبة
تحتفل ناتسوكو بهذا
باهتمامها  الجماليات
التي تنشط على وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
ومعروفة
بدمج شغفها بالفن والموضة الأخرى في عملية الطهي الخاصة بها
في الواقع ، إنها تريد استخدام هذه
الصناعات الأخرى لترقية القيمة
الإجمالية للطعام
[الموسيقى]
والفن والموضة معروفان
عالميًا بقيمتهما و  تقدر قيمتها بمئات
الملايين من
الدولارات وأعتقد أنها تنتج الفن أيضًا ،
وكذلك الطعام الجميل الذي يطبخه
الطهاة ويأكله عملاؤنا ، ينبغي
تقدير المزيد
من هاتسوكو التي تبث حياة جديدة في
مشهد الطهي التقليدي في اليابان
في عام 2020 ، لقد فازت بجائزة
أفضل طاهي معجنات في آسيا
اليوم تضع طموحاتها
أعلى وليس للأسباب التي قد تعتقد
أنه يتعين علينا تحقيق النتائج من
خلالها  جوائز لاف تحصل على مزيد
من الاهتمام من الجمهور وتتغير الطريقة التي
ينظر بها الناس إليك